le garde des sceaux entre le marteau et
l'enclume cet après-midi demarthe aussi
si vous voulez le congrès de
l'association légitime défense
l'enclume celui du syndicat de la
magistrature il n'était présent qu'au
second mais en son absence légitime
défense n'a pas des tendres puis 6e bull
l'association légitime défense ce n'est
cet après midi son congrès annuel
the dead du congrès ce fut bien sûr
lionel le gras le garagiste transistors
piégé récemment acquitté aux assises de
3 après la mort d'un cambrioleur
insécurité délinquance et criminalité
était à l'ordre du jour monsieur romerio
président légitime défense en est pris à
la pratique du droit d'asile et de
l'extradition
autant dire que le ministre de la
justice ou la cible des congressistes
nous raccrochons à monsieur badinter son
laxisme l'abolition de la peine de mort
le les poursuites
comment dirais-je
incomplète et ce par des malfaiteurs
je la libération presque immédiate de
ceux qui ont commis des méfaits ce qui
décourage la police et puis également le
fait de nous préparer un code pénal qui
d'après ce que nous savons est un
désastre et accentuera encore
l'insécurité pourtant très grand faim